[Music]
cloak-and-dagger has been renewed for
season two and it's about time we talked
about one of the most up-and-coming
Disney actresses olivia holt doesn't her
face look familiar to you
keep on watching to find out why don't
forget to hit that notification belt to
never miss another video and be sure to
check out our community section for even
more fun now let's check out some facts
about olivia holt she was on shake it up
Olivia might be starring in some pretty
popular and trendy shows but her acting
career came from humble and small
beginnings did you know a slightly
younger olivia holt actually appeared on
shake it up this was back in 2013 so
Olivia would be just 15 years old she
was supposed to play young Georgia but
doesn't her cameo kind of remind you of
Lizzie McGuire she definitely has the
hair to play the part but she also did
really good for Trang the young Georgia
too of course she had no clue who Tandy
Bowen was she was told very little about
the character before she actually came
to the audition she got just a tiny bit
of character breakdown but as she said
it herself it just really wasn't enough
Olivia also said she did her own
research and read the first comic to
understand Tandy more but as you'll
learn from the series she's quite a
complex character that's not easy to
portray during Olivia's audition she had
to be guided to better understand what
Tandy's actually going through but at
the end of the day she still had a
successful audition that landed her the
part she was a competitive gymnast
Olivia's love for gymnastics is very
real and it's something she talks about
often it's partially why she'll be an
absolutely perfect superhero character
she can basically do all of her own
stunts she was a competitive gymnast for
five years and as she stated herself she
actually really wanted to be at the
Olympics but what's even cooler is she
got to do the splits with the one and
only Gabby Douglas which is pretty cool
we can't we just see Liv's gymnastic
stunts but also kind of glad she took on
acting instead of the Olympics her
middle name is interesting olivia has a
pretty interesting middle name in case
you didn't know most people's middle
name reads as a first name but in Liv's
case it makes her full name look even
more powerful than before her middle
name is Hastings which means her full
name is Olivia Hastings Holt now that's
definitely a star quality name isn't it
Olivia Holt is catchy on its own but
there's just something about her full
name that makes her stand out even more
just imagine seeing Olivia Hastings hold
on a cast list for a Broadway show
total start
quality cloak-and-dagger took five
months to film but the whole reason
we're talking about Olivia in the first
place is because of the cloak-and-dagger
series who doesn't love a good series
about teenagers with superpowers it's
even better when this series is actually
based on Marvel Comics
Olivia stated that cloak-and-dagger
actually took five months to film and a
whole year to finish post-production
that's quite a long wait for something
as exciting as cloak-and-dagger but
totally worth it if you haven't seen the
series yet you really should give it a
try especially if you love supernatural
shows she has her own advice column
Olivia doesn't only have an acting
career this Disney star once kept
herself busy with her advice column
called hey Olivia which was a part of
Tiger Beat Magazine in 2016
Olivia also hosted a weekly show on
Radio Disney the show followed her life
as she prepared for her first ever
headlining tour and eov in case you
didn't know this talented star can also
sing her chops off we're telling you
she's got the looks the talent and the
personality to make it in this business
don't believe us keep on watching not
related to Claire holt
but let's get one thing straight a lot
of people seem to think there's some
kind of a connection between Olivia and
claire Holt who you might know from the
Vampire Diaries Olivia's family includes
her mother Kim father Marc sister Megan
and brother Kade there's no Claire Holt
in sight not even the slightest however
her sister whose last name is toll is
also an actress and heavily involved in
the production side of things when it
comes to movies and TV shows it seems
that these two are the only current
members of the Holt family that have
decided to pursue their acting skills
she loves scary movies scary movies are
like Marmite you either love them or you
totally hate them while it's always
strange to see how a person can enjoy
being scared it seems that olivia holt
is totally this person she admitted
she's a total fan of scary movies and
even said that the infamous
Halloweentown ones are her favorites do
you like scary movies or do you hate
them come let us know in the comments
truth be told they just seem a bit too
scary to fully enjoy and we can't even
imagine ever watching a scary movie
again after seeing it for the first time
she's a gamer
seriously what can't this a girl do she
sounds like she's good at just about
anything and one of the interviews Liv
said that she loves playing Call of Duty
which is a popular first-person shooter
game and we bet she's actually pretty
good at it
she also said she loves playing video
games with her little brother
what an adorable family bonding time we
might not ever get to play video games
with Olivia but it's probably for the
better because we definitely freak out
if we knew it was her on the other side
of the screen creative control of the
characters we mentioned that Olivia
didn't really know much about her
character before she walked in the cloak
and dagger auditions but the good news
is that since then the actors Liv
included have actually been heavily
involved with the direction of their
character
Olivia said that it was extremely
important to make sure the teen
characters are actually relatable she
also added that the entire team has had
in-depth conversations about the future
of these characters and that it's
definitely not over for these team
superheroes yet well we already know
that the show has been renewed for a
second season and we honestly can't wait
to see it
she immediately clicked with Aubree
Joseph olivia holt is pretty bubbly and
outgoing and she has no problems
becoming friends with just about any of
her cast members but she said that
meeting Aubree Joseph was a totally
magical moment she said that her and
Aubree immediately clicked and really
created something incredible both actors
were just as passionate about these
characters and the story which made
their scenes together that much more
real and it's very rare to instantly
connect with your fellow cast members
that quickly
this truly is a magical moment who knows
maybe Olivia actually does have some
hidden human superpowers she's not a
natural dancer Liv can pretty much do
anything she's good at sports she can
sing and she can act but one thing that
Olivia herself has pointed out is that
she's actually not a natural dancer
while she can easily repeat the moves of
someone else she said she can't move
naturally when it comes to freestyling
we just feel like she's pretty hard on
herself because we've all seen that
these boots are made for walking
performance on shake it up and she did
just fine she was on a whole new level
of sassy in that one she was obsessed
with Lizzie McGuire here's a blast from
the past remember how we said earlier
Liv look like Lizzie McGuire in one of
her early TV appearances well that might
not actually have been a coincidence
because this girl seriously idolized the
show
she watched Disney Channel all the time
growing up and she said she had all
Lizzie McGuire merchandise which is
pretty impressive that must have been
such a surreal moment to appear on a TV
channel she loved to watch as a kid a
true this is what dreams are made of
moment the Lizzie McGuire character was
able to relate to as well
she loves popcorn everyone has their
favorite comfort food whether it's
chocolate doughnuts pizza or anything
else there's just something about it
that makes us
smile but for Liv that food is popcorned
she said she loves smart food white
cheddar popcorn the most but she also
loves movie theater popcorn we feel you
Liv
popcorns just the best but she also said
that she got everyone on said hook to
popcorn dipped in Nutella which is
genius sure it might be messy but that's
just pure genius comfort food we're
craving right now be right back
we're buying popcorn and Nutella right
now Dave Franco is her celebrity crush
yup you heard that right
Dave Franco might be born in 1985 which
is 12 years before olivia holt but that
doesn't stop her from crushing on him
you might know dave franco from movies
like now you see me and bad neighbors
live even acknowledge that Dave's way
too old for her but her other crush is
kim chang gandhi who's married and has a
kid so she just sticks to Dave Franco
well we want to hear an update to her
celeb crushes considering that dave
Franco got married to Alison Brie in
2017 she's obsessed with ketchup popcorn
isn't her only comfort food and dunking
it in at Ella isn't the only good thing
this girl does she's also one of those
people that just adores ketchup to the
obsessively extreme amounts in an
interview she said that she eats
everything with ketchup every single
meal we're sure there are some
exceptions to that rule but she does say
that she really can't eat a meal without
smothering ketchup on it and the best
part is she carries a ketchup bottle in
her purse suddenly we want Liv to do a
what's in my purse challenge this girl
is cray-cray
she gets along with everyone Liv is just
one of the friendliest actresses you'll
ever meet we already discussed how her
and Aubrey Joseph instantly clicked when
they came into the audition for cloak
and dagger but they weren't the only
ones all her ex cast mates are her close
friends her bubbly personality
definitely comes from her mantra her
advice to young girls wanting to make it
in the entertainment industry is to
always have fun and let passion guide
you through the challenging work she
also said that you should stay who you
are and surround yourself with good
people and by the looks of it that is
definitely what she seems to be doing
what a humble actress she was a
cheerleader we're telling you there's
nothing this girl can't do along with
her gymnastics abilities Olivia also
revealed that she was involved in a lot
of school activities including cheer
seriously her school schedule seems
pretty packed she was even on the cover
for the American cheerleader magazine
where she stated that she lives breathes
and sweats cheer she also said that
cheerleading taught her all about having
respect for all her teammates which is
definitely a trait she uses an
they're areas of her life too and just
like in gymnastics she did plenty of
stunts as a cheerleader too we seriously
can't wait to see how all this stunt
knowledge helps her interacting she
released an EP in 2016 after Olivia left
kick in it she announced later that year
that she signed to Hollywood Records in
2016 she released her first EP called
Olivia she previously already released a
single called carry on but this was the
first time we were able to hear Liv's
voice on an album and let us tell you
this girl can really sing in July 2018
she was also featured on Martin Jenson
single sixteen steps and we really have
a feeling that's not the last time we'll
talk about her music she really is a
triple threat and we have no doubt
she'll soon be one of the most
talked-about Disney actresses started
her career in commercials if her face
looks familiar to you you might have
spotted her in commercials without even
realizing do you remember that Bratz
commercial where an actual Bratz doll
came to life the kid talking to that
doll was Olivia you could also see her
in commercials like the girl gourmet
cupcake maker as well as several others
we're telling you this chick has had a
long career before she joined the cast
of cloak-and-dagger and from the looks
of it it can only go up from here we
can't wait to see what's next in store
for this Disney star and we absolutely
can't wait for season 3 of cloak and
dagger and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]